lives turned upside down
this was the door to a balcony
that no longer exists
valentina was sleeping here when the
explosion happened
she and her teenage daughter are lucky
to be alive
[Music]
residents and pets in this neighborhood
in eastern kiev left stunned as the
reality of russia's invasion hit home
they're unclear what caused the crater
with one man suggesting it happened
after ukraine's air defenses intercepted
an incoming russian airstrike
the worse the fighting gets the greater
the risk becomes for civilians of
getting caught in the middle residents
at this apartment block described how
they were woken up at between 4 4 30 in
the morning by a loud explosion they
said the night sky lit up like daylight
and when dawn broke they found this
devastation
russia's invading troops identifiable by
the zed are attacking from the north
east and south
the plan seems to be to take control of
the southern coastline such as here in
hassan and push into the east
[Music]
this ukraine's second city of kharkiv
under heavy bombardment
terrifying for residents and challenging
for ukraine's military as other russian
forces close in on the capital
a battle for this airfield in the
northwest of kiev finally won by russian
troops after heavy fighting
a sign of things to come perhaps
russia's president called on ukrainian
forces effectively to switch allegiances
using false smears about ukraine's
leaders
systems
watch the apparent russian military
vehicle crush a car in the north of the
capital the driver lucky to escape
yet russia is suffering losses too
this aircraft was shot down over kiev by
ukrainian forces
our assessment as of this morning is
that russia has not taken any of its
major objectives in fact it is behind
its hoped-for timetable
they've lost over 450 personnel
and indeed as you've said on your report
one of the significant airports they
were trying to capture with their elite
spetsnaz has failed to be taken and in
fact the ukrainians have taken it back
but this isn't just a conventional war
listen to the gunfight at this security
office in the southern city of molitopol
as it's attacked by soldiers who don't
have obvious markings on their uniform
russian special forces are thought to be
on the ground conducting sabotage
missions
the ultimate goal to topple the
president here on friday
even civilians are being handed weapons
and urged to fight
a sign of desperation but also of the
prospect of a grinding guerrilla war
that could in the end cost russia dearly
too
debrahing sky news kiev